Yeah, so
with our electronic challenges here, today,
it's a pleasure to welcome Michael Glinsky.
Many of whom, at least in the plasma
physics world at the lab know him.
He has a 30 year career focused on data
science, deep learning, Bayesian data analysis,
which is going to be very popular with our crew.
I've guarantee worked in laboratories like ours,
but also companies like a Royal
Dutch Shell, BHP Halliburton,
the list goes on lnl, Sandia faculty member in
the physics department in Western Australia.
Again, going back to some of our laser interaction
community here was a key member of the team that
founded in basics, and NEA lead investor firm
aiming at laser treatments for ischemic stroke.
In terms of your deep dark past, you got
your PhD from UCSD in physics, and in fact,
did postdoctoral work here on ICF. And Mike is
currently the CEO of B and Z energy incorporated.
Which scribed here is a disruptive
investment and operating company
for the energy transition
powered by AI risk management.
The just just want to say before I give the
title of this talk and turn things over to
him is we have a fairly flexible schedule today
if people want to come by and and talk to Mikey,
when we've changed the room, he will be in
building for anyone but on in room 2117, which
is I think that's the old MIT guest office. And
then with that, I'll turn this over to Mike who's
going to talk about a physics based reduced order
model capturing the topology of dynamic manifolds.
I'll leave it to you.
Okay, thanks very much, Steve. And that, you
know, this work really started with probably
back in about 2011, when I ended up seeing
stuff on the lot, talk first about his deep
convolutional transformation called the scattering
transform. And that when I saw it, initially,
I saw a lot of things that started ringing bells
in terms of quantum field theory in my mind, they,
you know, he was talking about Vic ordering,
path ordering type things in there. Also,
there were just also other things ringing in the
back of my head with respect to renormalization
group two associated with it. Also, it seemed
to have some connection, also, in my mind,
to Werner Heisenberg, S matrix and the scattering
matrix. And in fact, he called it the scattering
transform, because I was talking about the S
matrix, and even the name ended up coming from
some of my heroes, because I've actually
been a collaborator of stuff on Melotte.
that dates back to probably the early 2000s.
And one of the first we actually deployed into
Debashis, proximal gradient methods, even
before it was published in terms of sparse
spike in version four, or D convolution for
seismic data, and may have worked spectacularly
well as it has and many of the other areas of
data science. And but I struggled with this for
decades, and actually over a decade about trying
to understand the relationships or different
attempts that I made at it, you know, and but it
just really never had, but the one thing that I
realized along the way was that it was performing
extremely well. And that in terms of being able
to crack problems that hadn't been cracked before
things in terms of texture recognition of where
people were, you know, had very poor maybe 20%
miscalculate, you know, misclassifications when
they ended up going using this, taking the
logarithm of it, and then using just simple
linear discrimination methods, they were getting
performances, which was state of art in less than
5% misclassification. And so, I kept on scratching
my head to I mean, and associated with that,
and then also a man I went and had been talking
also with John field who had been working at this
laboratory at the time, and he kept on going and
saying, hey, does this have something to do or in
terms of artificial intelligence with topology,
right and some type of topological distance type
Both of analysis. And, you know, you know,
fortunately, since I've left Sandia National
Laboratory, and founded this company,
and we were in the startup phase of it,
that I had the ability to really set up my,
you know, put up my feed on my front porch,
have good morning coffees, and really think
profoundly about this stuff. And I've never
really had that luxury before. And what
I'm going to go and present here is,
that is based off of some work I did under
contract with Sandia after I left there,
and that I really tried some stuff in there work
spectacularly well, in terms of a workflow. And
then subsequent to that, and I'll talk a little
bit about the scientific exploration method that,
you know, I ended up going through that I ended
up going and I think, really cracking and not
on this ride. And that is actually this is a
slide I put together this morning. And that
that means that changing
actually, is there a problem?
Without Okay, okay, it's just taking
a while to go through that, you know,
this is actually going and is challenging
a lot of paradigms, right. And that,
I mean, I think that even ourselves, we don't
realize that things like quantum mechanics,
actually actually have gone from a critically
developed theory to a matter of paradigm or dogma,
of where we go and recite things without
really thinking critically about it. And here,
I'm going to be going and taking a look at
artificial intelligence, and to think critically
about something, you know, I was taught in
terms of leadership, executive coaching,
that you really need to go and start asking
yourself questions, right. And I want to go and I
don't expect you to answer I. But as I go through
the talk, and this exploration is to go and start
thinking critically about what we're doing in
artificial intelligence, right. And that these
were questions that I ended up going and asking
myself as I was going and developing and stuff,
right. Okay, first of all, what are the variables
when we have these nodes and reduced order models?
Right? Because if you go and take a look at
the architectures that tend to be successful,
they have bottlenecks, right, in terms of their
structure, right? Whether or not that be auto
encoders. Okay, and I'll be talking about some
of those specific structures here, whether or
not they be unit structures, right. Whether or
not they be, you know, things like, you know,
based off the David Silver's deep reinforcement
learning DQ ends, or whether or not they BGP T's,
right, these things all have choke points in
it, right, where they're forcing the fit, right,
actually find some type of reduced order model in
terms of those limited nodes at the choke points,
right. What are those things, right? And in
the context of deep reinforcement learning in,
you know, Q learning, that if you go and
look at the feature value, iteration, right,
they have the status, right, okay. And that,
that things are not truly done that way, but
you'll go and see what our theta right in there,
right. And I was Sarah taught in my grad course,
on artificial intelligence at Carnegie Mellon,
that you could choose anything, and we I don't
think there's a statement that can be farther from
the truth thrive. There are very specific things
that you need, what what those are, and you'll see
me go and, and and actually answer this question,
right. And then also, if we go and you have
all these deep convolutional networks, right,
these are functional transformations, right?
Going from a function space to a function space,
right, from a Hilbert space to a Hilbert
space. Well, that's a Banach space,
right? We're searching a Banach space, right?
Well, that's like impossible, right? Okay.
And so what do we have to do we always make DT
really constraining assumptions about the form
of that functional transformation, even then
we can be left with a billion parameters. So
we have regularization techniques to go
and further reduce the number of actual
independent parameters in the model so
that we can fit it with a finite number.
Maybe 10,000 samples or
something of that nature, right?
And but our brain guide comes pre programmed with
thrived and we don't go and have to do anything,
right, it's evolved to have a very particular
convolutional network structure. Right. So
ask yourself the question, why do we spend
10s and millions of dollars? Learning what
these structures are? on a case by case basis?
Right. Okay. I mean, you know, like, our brain
just comes that way, right? I mean, I think that
you realize, well, we transfer learn a lot. Well,
yeah, I mean, you're learning this probably the
structure of this deep convolutional network.
Right. And so, you know, and then an associated
question is, what is the deep convolution,
all our functional transformation doing? Right?
You know, and I really started, you know, those
were my introspection questions about what we're
doing and needs to make some sense right. Now,
I had the sort of cheeky question What is Q
learning? Right? Okay. I mean, that is what
is key. Right, you know, when you doing deep
Q learning, what is the Q function? Right?
Okay. Think about it. Right. Okay. And then, you
know, John fields question right in which was a
real proposal by him? Is artificial intelligence
related to the topology and geometry of the
system's dynamic and dynamical manifold, right?
Are we learning what the homology class is? Of
the of the topology? Are we learning about
what those singularities are? Right? Okay.
Oh, no, maybe. Okay, the next one. Okay.
Is there a physical justification for
rectified linear units? Right. I mean, you
know, from the early parts of my career,
that neural networks were not very successful,
multi layer perceptrons weren't really
successful. The advent of the rectified
linear unit was like Nirvana was reached,
right. When you put those things on there,
right. Why mean? Well, you know, I mean,
you know, is there a physical justification for
why you're using rectified linear units? Right.
The next thing is, why is the logarithms
so important? Right, okay. You know,
that this may not be I think, but you it seems
to be you want to throw logarithmic transforms
on things to make them more, right. Okay. And it's
very explicit in what Stefan Melotte did with the
scattering transformation. One thing he actually
even berries and sometimes doesn't even tell you,
because he always takes the logarithm
of it, right. And in my work that I did,
based off of Gorgan, I always had I tried to
take the logarithm before as well as after,
right, okay. And actually, I should
have been taking it in between two,
but that was a little bit hard to do.
Because Stefan never embedded that in
his transformation. Right. And like, then
everything's linear. Like, what? Huh? Okay.
You know, linear methods work, you know, and they
work as well as anything. Right. And they have
fantastic performance, right. And then also, and
this goes to, I don't know, people that have been
out there and have had interactions and Pedro's
off am. But he's been talking about stud pulses,
right. And he's been doing that, you
know, talking about it for quite a while,
right. Well, that, you know, I go and think
of it, is it an equivalent of ponder mode
of stabilization in deep reinforcement learning?
Right? And is that what Bedros is talking about,
with respect to start policies? Right.
When I hear him give those talks,
I started having a lot of Oh, ponder mode of
stabilization type thoughts associated with it,
right? And can we do something like that? Right.
And with that said, let me go and jump in to my
slide of equations, right? And that after
this, this is the one slide of equations.
I'm going to walk you through
just what the steps are. Okay,
here. But the thing that I'm going to go
and want to get and show you in the end,
and the magic thing is this recursion
relation, okay. And you can see that
recursion relation has it's a layer of a
convolutional network, okay? In this case with a
set of scaled wavelets. Okay, it's scaled Wavelet
Transformation, where p is the scale of the way
the transformation, and then it has a activation
or rectifier, okay. And that because this is now
going to go and be a, it's a recursion relation
that you can go up and get to the nth order thing
by applying the recursion relation m times. So
we end up with a convolutional deep convolutional
network, where the layers are the, you know,
each time that we apply it in the product. So it
will have little lamb layers associated with it,
right? Where this actually is what you normally
would go and use a real use for okay, but instead,
okay, you actually have I, because it's a complex
transformation, you have a logarithm, and are
not basically gives you one plus x so that when
you take the logarithm of one plus x and x is
small, that you end up finding that for small x,
actually log x equals x. And since we're going
to be going and applying this again, and again,
if we don't have that property, you actually see
it blows up. Right? Okay. So for convergence,
math reasons, you need to go and have that
in there. Right? Okay. And so how do we go
and get to this formula, okay. And I will
go and talk about the gray box after I get
one to go and relate it to what the normal
rectifiers are that we ended up using,
right? And so let's just start start with a
normal Taylor expansion of a complex function
okay. And that the Taylor expansion coefficients
okay are just obviously the derivatives Okay,
of whatever that function is. And that this
is also though go and I will go and realize
these are the S matrix, okay. In terms of what
the N particle scattering coefficients are, I
will assume that h sub m is actually a functional
of the fields and the CO momentums of the fields,
okay, I define a convolutional wavelet transform,
okay, here the standard definition of a wavelet
transform, I consider an analytic trajectory,
which is parameterized by x, that's nothing more
than the convolution Okay, of the wavelet. With
that, I take the CO vector along the trajectory by
taking D of that, I changed the radial coordinates
about z naught, which is a little bit of
inspiration at this point. So I actually get
the property at the end and took a little bit
of fiddling as you may expect, I rotate by pi
over two to get the CO vector by multiplying
by AI. And so I find that d h sub m is
equal to d of I logs z, okay? And then
with this simple definition of what are the
are not function is it's a analytic function,
I ended up going and getting what the recursion
relation is right? But this is a logarithmic
generating function of a complex Hamiltonian,
right? And okay, complex Hamiltonian what? Okay,
well, that the real part of the Hamiltonian
is the Hamiltonian that we go know and love,
right? And so you go and you specify
that and what's the imaginary part? Well,
you actually don't have any freedom, there
is a complex analytic continuation of that
and of the real part of the Hamiltonian, so you
get the complex part is just the natural analytic
continuation of it right. But also that normally
if you go and take a look at quantum field theory,
you always deal with respect to exponential
generating functional so i e to the generator
e to the i a try. But by taking the logarithm, you
actually get a generating function of directly of
the Hamiltonian. And that's also the reason
why the logarithm is being introduced inside
of it. Right. Okay. And now let me talk
a little bit about what this activation
function or what the rectifier is here,
right? Think a little bit back into your
days of complex analysis about what is
the complex logarithm, right? Okay. The
complex longer than the real part of it is
the natural logarithm of the modulus, okay?
And that the argument with the imaginary part of
it is the phase or the argument of the complex
number, right? Okay. So that if you now go and
first of all, take a look at log of r naught,
as z goes to zero, okay goes to the identity. So
we don't have problems. It's a compact mapping,
okay, here's what that basically says. And then if
I now go and take Z going to infinity, I actually
go and find that it goes to log modulus,
right? Well, the scattering transformation
has the law, it has the modulus in it. So if
I take log of the scattering transformation,
okay, I mag and also take the log of the
signal, take the scattering transformation
of it in the first order, then take the log of
it, I've actually gone two things in this limit,
right? Okay. And it actually should be in between
every step of the deep convolutional network,
just not at the end. But log of log as long
as you do log two times, basically, it is
sorry.
Coming from my ignorance.
So is what's going on here is we have a set of
dynamical variables that we're going to try to
use to much more efficiently describe, I think, in
your case, it's going to be a pulse power thing or
something like that. And there's an there's a kind
of an equation of motion for that that comes from,
you know, whatever the original equation was, and
so is what you're doing, telling us how so there's
a Hamiltonian that evolves that system, there's a
Hamilton Jacobi equation in those funny variables
of the partial differential equation, which
is my problem is what you're describing here,
a are going to be a transformation of the
variables in which you describe that system,
making it more efficient. putting words in your
mouth, but there you go. Well, I got it yet, yet.
Yes. Okay. But let me just go and I'll give you
the answer. You're asking for what the answer yes.
Right. Okay. I mean, right now, I'm developing
an answering the question why log? Right. Okay.
But what you want is actually, what what's
happening? State is that you are going from
the field basis. Right. Okay. And you're going
into a renormalization basis where it's a basis
where that each one, you'll find that there are
a certain number of spectrums complex spectrums,
right? Okay. And you're decomposing into
each one of those complex spectrums,
right? And so you're going in say, if you have
a complex spectrum beta of frequency, right and
phase that now you go into and you project
the motion is going to lie on a hyperplane,
which is the projection into the renormalization
basis, right? So you've gone from motion on
a Hilbert space in the deeply convoluted field
domain, and you've actually exposed a small number
of dynamical P's and Q's by actually projecting
on to the solution of the renormalization group
equations right okay. And then it becomes
a simple matter of finding out what the
solutions are to the Hamilton Jacobi equation,
right? In that domain. Why is why is I mean,
so the original variables and mutations of them
come from a you know, rad hydro or some or pulse
power some their feelings. Yeah. So why is there a
Hilbert space here? That's not about being because
it may comes about because you actually
have a function of position, right fields
are something they are defined as a function of
positions. They're actually functions throughout
Okay, and so that you're actually seeing how
functions actually are transformed with time. And
so the basic, instead of having a finite number
of P's and Q's, right, okay, you actually have
something that's actually a for function, which
is an element. It's continuous function. That's
an element of a Hilbert space, right? And so that
whenever you deal with field equations, you're
going and that the be your VA, you are dealing
with something that's actually fundamentally an
evolution of a function, rather than an evolution
of a certain number of discrete variables.
Well, yeah,
but I don't know, we can have more
questions, but my follow up question is,
okay, so you saw having some sort of space?
And then there's a mapping from the space to
the old snow manifold, where that's right.
Yeah. And that is your building? And no,
I mean, you go and see, why don't I just go and
just finish up showing the relationships to the
previous functional transformations that we have.
And the next slide is really talking about
this, right? And that you can go and also,
it's really what's going to be developed on
the next couple slides. Okay. And so let me
just go and finish this. And again, I'm going
to immediately return to your question, okay,
and the like. And that, you also can go and
show that this is effectively logs z times
a chirp pulse, okay. And that what Stefan when he
tried to bring in, phase into this, ended up going
and replacing the chirp Paul's, with a series of
harmonics and decomposing with respect to that,
right. He didn't look at it this way. But I'm
showing the connection to the rectifier unit,
right. And if you only use the leading order
term, or the k equals zero, harmonic, you end
up getting down to just the modulus, which is what
he implemented in his scattering transformation.
Okay. And so now let's go on and really get into
what's your talk, what you were getting at Steve,
and also what you were asking about, right?
Okay. Is that you go and you're starting here,
in terms of this basically Bondoc space of all
functionals. Right, okay. And this logarithmic
generating functional takes you down to the
Hilbert space of all possible spectrums,
right, okay. And because of the fact that
this is a logarithmic generating function,
you're going to go and find that you're limited
to a fairly low dimensional subspace. And in fact,
the dimension of that is going to be
the, it's going to be two times little n,
where n is the number of fields, okay? In the
problem, or it's going to be basically CN.
So you can do a principal components analysis
on this, you'll see that all of the variation
ends up being in a hyperplane that you can
find with a principal components analysis,
right? And those directions are those that is a
set of measures zero, right? For MHD that I'll
be showing you little n is seven, there are seven
fields associated with it, right, okay. And that,
that when you go and literally find what these
principal components are, each one is going to
be a complex spectrum. We're going to go and
actually show the example of where you actually
have seven complex spectrums, right. And if you
went through the normal Wilson procedure and
solved for those spectrums, right, you would
have now the same spectrum is okay. And so,
by making the functional transformation, and then
find the PCA you find again, the basis vectors and
those basis vectors are the renormalization group
equation. And you can project the original motion
in the field domain Okay. Into a motion in a in
the beta domain which are the projection into
Those little n principal components that you
actually have of the motion, right? Okay. I think
you now realize that the the coordinates in, you
know, projected into this, which I go and say are
the beta coordinates, right? Are the reduced order
model that or the first cut at the reduced order
model that you're looking at. Right? Okay. But
now to go and further understand what's happening,
right, is that you actually need to go and
find a function approximator that needs to
go and approximate a analytic function, which
is the complex Hamiltonian, right? And this
actually goes to the second reason why you'd like
rectified linear units, because this one will now
just have a few singularities in it, right? The
CO homology classes of it, right, okay. And,
and I call those the beta stars, or all
are these beta naught K's, right, okay,
which you can go and also, if you're
familiar with Taylor relaxation, in,
in stellarator, is, for instance, that you
go, and you'll see that you energy minimize,
but you actually go down to kind of these
ground states, but these ground states
end up being the cohomology class, and
are actually the, there's a topological
obstruction that you have to go around, you
can go to just sort of zero motion, right.
And that the mean, it's like you had a topology
of a torus, right? If you go in around either the,
you know, that you can find that there are a lot
of loops, if you go around the center, or you
go around the edge of the doughnut, you can't go
and shrink that, that trajectory to zero, because
you're limited by the topological obstruction
of the T two tours, and there are two of them,
you know, obviously, with respect to the T two
tours associated with it, right. But those end
up acting as boundary conditions on any type of
analytic function. Because if you go and tell me,
you know, the poles and zeros of the knowing that
have an analytic function and the branch cuts,
that that's a boundary condition, you solve the
pluses equation, and that gives you the analytic
functions so that knowing the the effectively
poles and zeros of branch cuts of the function
are equivalent to actually knowing what the
analytic function is, right? Are you saying that
kind of makes sense to me to have a dynamical
system that's got lots of variables that you know,
that obey some complicated equation, you're
saying, before you take the step of casting
it? In this description, you have to
discover if there's any underlying
non trivial topology? And I guess from my
own broad perspective, would you do that?
Basically, by taking loops, you know, in the
space, and then just trying to see what Stokes
theorem says, right? Isn't that what it is? Yeah,
you can go and do that. But also, you can map out,
I don't know how often you have to do it, but
maybe a lot, right. But you also see, you can also
map out the trajectories. Right? Okay. Love it,
right. And, you know, just you just have to map
out little bits of the trajectories and then go
and see how they end fine. And by that you start,
you can go and reconstruct the analytic
Hamiltonian. Right? Okay. So how often is
it? Or maybe you're gonna tell us, you know, in
a practical example, that, you know, that loops,
you run into a set of variables that have
some kind of topological obstruction or
something like that, that you got to fix or
drive around or whatever? Is that is that a
common events? When you have many variables
like that? I would think it might be Oh, yeah,
no, no, there aren't many of them.
Right. Okay. And that also, I mean,
if you go and Bedros also has another concept.
He talks about his bars and stars, right.
I think forget now what those acronyms are
cheapy things that Bezos always comes up with,
but that he goes and he really talks about why do
we keep on slightly perturbing trajectories and
then integrating them all again, in a very hard
way, right. And if we look at nearby trajectories,
that you should be following those
nearby trajectories. Right. Okay.
And what you're looking at here is that
if you're trying to map out one of the
These analytic functions, right? Is that, you
know, you really can go and easily interpolate
them because analytic functions are maximally
flat, right? And that's what a solution to
Laplace equation is, right? Except for these
few singularities, right? That's why rectified
linear units are so good, because when you
combine those into a multi layer perceptron,
you get a piecewise linear function approximator,
right, which is maximally flat, right? Except for
places where you have a singularity, which means
you have a disconnect this continuity in the first
derivative, right? Okay. And that also tells
you why sigmoids are like spectacularly bad,
because they are infinitely smooth, and they can
handle the few singularities that you need. But
you don't need many of those tie points, right,
you just need to have one of the points beyond the
singularity. And it's very easy for a multi layer
perceptron to figure out where to put the cost.
And then they go, and you'll see a nice example,
it finds where the cost is puts the cost there,
and it goes out and is flat as you go away from
there. Right. Okay. And it also goes and says
that these things will extrapolate. Well, just
so you're moving away from a singularity, where
you've actually sampled it, right? Because it just
goes flat. I think John field talks about this,
right? But if for some reason you are, you're
starting to get into a part of parameter space,
where you're walking towards one of these
singularities, right, you will actually
see things are and we don't have it in your
model, you actually see things start getting
worse. Right? Okay. And that's telling you that
there's an additional singularity. And you better
go and have a, you know, start sampling those
simulations, right? And it can also tell you that,
is there actually a beta that's not in your model,
right? Are you missing a term in your partial
differential equations that you're seeing in the
experiment, right. But if you actually went in,
let's say, did the experiment, and you actually
saw there was an additional beta in there, that
was not actually part of the what was coming out
of your computer simulations, where you actually
know what beta is, you know, the spectrum of it,
you know, the spectrum of the partial differential
operator, so that you know that there is a piece
of physics you're missing. And you also know what
the spectrum of that partial differential operator
are. And that you probably can go and invert back
for what the term is, will give you large clues to
what the physics is that you actually don't have,
or improperly approximating in your simulations.
Right. Okay. And I think that we all know, as we
start scaling up these devices, the paranoia, we
have we neglected something that's now going to
become important in the physics fry, or is it an
extrapolation away from well known singularities
in the function, right? But you know, going
and taking a look at just what these complex
Hamiltonians end up being right, is that you can
either map out what that function is, or what the
phase space looks like, what the trajectories
look like, or actually what the foliation is,
or you can actually go and just know
what those that those limited number
of singularities are. Right? Okay? But
also, what's the real problem is that here,
we have a couple of poles and zeros or brands
cut, okay? And I'll show you an example of that
with a simple analytic function, the earth oil
function, right? What happens when you you know,
there is a full read transformation, but
also there is an inverse transformation,
okay? A well defined inverse. All right.
And so that, what you're going to go and
understand here is that we're going to go and
we're going to do a full read transformation
into okay, this coordinate system, right?
And then you're going to want to go and to
do predictions or to find out what to apply
to the system. If you're controlling it,
you're going to want to do the
inverse transformation. Okay. So
now we'll actually more specifically
show that on some other things.
Right, okay. But what you're going to go and
see is that we go and we have this convolutional
network. And we have some bottleneck here. Okay?
In this case, there's too little n plus one for
energy. And I'll talk about that in a second.
And then you actually go and expand it back
out. And so that's how you go. And you see, then
at this point, this is the reduced order model
of the system, right? And I'm just going
and showing things in the forward sense,
right? Okay. But what we actually get into, and
it's what we the problem that Ken Wilson had to to
frontally address with respect to renormalization.
What is a very simple pole, in this case, when you
actually go backwards and go back to the fields,
since it's a deep convolution, okay? It basically
takes this one pole and spreads it everywhere.
And so there are singularities everywhere you
look back in the field domain, right? And
so what happens in classic renormalization,
and what that's actually doing is taking all of
the singularities and smashing them back together
and collecting them in this reduced order model
space. Right? Okay. You have to be careful that
you don't basically throw the baby out in the
bathwater. Because a lot of times people would go
and you'd have when they go and solve the say
the Hamilton Jacobi equation, everybody loves
viscosity solutions, okay? Buyer Beware, your
L to regularizing all of the singularities out,
right? They do it because in the field, you
see singularities everywhere you look, you
gotta get rid of them, right. So let's go and L to
regularize, and get rid of all the singularities.
Unfortunately, you're getting rid of the one
singularity that you want in the process,
right? Because you're not being careful about it.
Right. And so you know, that it's actually done
all over the place and finance, right, it's called
interest, right, is basically resistivity right
L to regularization. And they really destroy the
economy's in the process of actually imposing it
physically on the system. Because when the Fed
goes and, and loans you money at a prime rate,
they actually are embedding viscosity into
the system, and fundamentally regularizing
the singularities out and destroying they
can destroy the the the stable points, that
and I'll show you that in a bit. Or they can and
malai. Right. So now let me go. And also, though,
too, is that what we're really doing is looking
at things in terms of extended phase space. Right?
Okay. And that this Hamiltonian, is actually
this complex Hamiltonian is actually operating
on the extended face space. And I'll talk about
that a bit more in a bit. But let me go back
and take another look at what's happening
once we get into these little cues. And PS.
Have to wait for things to update. So
just, you know, forgive the one commenter,
I don't know how long we have in the room.
Okay, so I, you know, would suggest, you know,
bringing things to a place also where people
may have questions. Because I, you know, again,
I don't know, I don't know, the laser, but
you know, we might be kicked out in five
minutes. Okay. I hope not. Okay. Well, that now
go and skip forward, since really, I Okay. Okay.
Let me go and skip forward to
a physics example. Right. And
that means what we actually do is,
and this goes back to my PhD thesis, and it's a
motion, the guiding center motion of an electron
in a
in a strong magnetic field,
and you can go and actually have a moving
ion associated with it. And that once you
actually go and want to see here, and then we'd be
rather quick about in terms of the control theory,
is that you end up going and seeing that you
actually have associate the EC electron you
have the O point and you have an
X point which is a saddle point.
I mean, these are local minimums, these
are local maximums on the saddles,
you also respect to the eye on have the O point
for it. And you also have an X point, okay,
sitting out here at infinity, okay? And that you
have what are either these guiding center atoms,
which are basically an electron bouncing back
and forth on the field line, and slowly e cross
V drifting around. Or you actually have both
the, these drifting pairs, which are ions and
electrons that basically are both going around
there cyclotron motion and drifting each other.
And you have free ones, right? Okay. But the thing
that you actually want, and the point that you'd
like to be at, you know, in most cases, are these
inverted pendulum, these maximum, local maximum,
but they're unstable, right? And that, because
basically omega equals zero at this point,
and because the mass is equal to one over omega
squared, if I just go and try to jiggle these
things, they don't jiggle if I'm at the point.
And the farther I get away from it, because the
mass is reduced, they go back and forth more, and
I jiggle them more, that causes a ponder mode of
stabilization for song, this. And that. And also
right here that I'm sorry, that you probably saw
that you can actually stabilize and invert
inverted pendulum by juggling it up and down,
right, okay, associated with it. And that what I
think bade Rose is talking about with stud pulses,
is the fact that you can't just dribble it anyway,
there are going to be in this case, you know,
a few characteristics spectrums, which is a set
of measures zero of however you could jiggle it,
and you need to go and jiggle it with those
characteristic spectrums. Right, okay.
I also went and went and did a whole
large ensemble of Gorgan simulations of
maglev and went and did them for different
initial temperatures, liner aspect ratios,
which is effectively the growth rate of the
instability and how aggressive the implosion is,
are the growth rate of the Rayleigh Taylor
instability. And because these were 2d in the,
in the radial direction, and you end up having
vorticity conserved, you actually see an inverse
cascade, and these things go and pinch into a
dumbbell, and then go out that you don't have
the normal, regular cascade associated
with it. Okay. And that, will you say,
well, in 3d, you lose that? No, you don't, you
actually have eliciting magnetic complicity,
rather than vorticity in 3d. And we actually
see you actually go to basically a dumbbell
double helix is what it looks like
in 3d, where it just rotates around.
That I ended up going and doing a
large number of the simulations about 539 on RZ,
topaz, that generated about 100,000
images, it took about 200,000 core hours,
about two weeks into sitting on the
machine, the MT, they would give me
the training of this workflow, which is what I
talked about here, I have a log I have an MST,
I have a log, I have a PCA, and then I have one
of these multi layer perceptrons with 15 layers
in the middle of it right. The training took about
16 GPU hours on my Linux workstation, the take the
MSTs and about a day to take the wavelet phase
harmonics, but it only took one core second to
find the principal components and 20 core seconds
to train the multi layer perceptron right, because
it's a very simple architecture, but then I had
a surrogate that actually executed and a 10th of
a core second and simulates what took 360 core
hours on the computer to go and simulate right.
And that this goes and shows the
this the actual simulation versus the generated
if both the density and for the magnetic
field at three different characteristic times,
right as the implosion you know the initial
condition, as the implosion starts near
Bang time. And after it's gone
and expanded out. i You notice
that it preserves also the correlation between the
two fields, as well as many of the
details of the of the simulation.
Yeah. So quick question. Really simple.
Get back to the picture. So which is the
brute force? You know, simulation? That is the
truth? Is it the one of the left or the right,
or? I'm sorry? The one on the left? That's the
truth. Yeah, I'm sorry, for some reason,
my annotation didn't know on the right,
we're seeing your, your, your method and play
your reduced order model. That's the reduced?
Yes, that is exactly right. And those are
lineouts of the two. So you can actually see,
you know, the quantitative similarities,
the quantitative, right, and then you
gave answers for how long it took to
do The GroundTruth simulation versus,
you know, this sort of slick way of
sort of redoing your variables. Yeah.
And that was 360 core hours to a 10th of
a second. Okay, what is the actual focus?
It's a brilliant liner. And the
know, the, the circle is beryllium.
And the internal part is
DD. So I guess the question is, how well does the
reduced order model due on macroscopic
quantities like yield and things? Like?
Yeah, we didn't have we didn't
have the physics in there,
I was looking at the ability of it
to, to do a surrogate on the field. So
because, and also to go and to understand the,
the fact of what's actually happening by because
if you go and take a look at the FY two component,
right, okay, that was associated with
the dipole perturbation of the shell,
right? You actually go and that you go and
you see, as you're actually come in here,
that the strength of this mode increases, and you
obviously see the dipole character of it, right,
okay. For the quadrupole character, you actually
see a decrease strike, there ends up being an
inverse cascade of energy from here to here, okay.
And we also are finding in terms of these modes,
they actually mean something in terms of
physically what's happening. And if I take
a look at, you know, how one of these compounds
goes with time, that you go and see now that
the actual you know, or the light curves and the
simulated are the dark curves, that you see that
it finds where the bang time is associated with
this, it goes and goes and then fits it linearly,
puts one of the tie points on the bank time, and
then also does you know, puts the right number of
tie points to follow the curve, right? It goes and
finds the one with the last largest aspect ratio,
the most acceleration comes, goes and, you know,
goes and hits, you know, has a shorter bang time,
it also goes and shows that as I go to a higher
temperature at a bat, it actually doesn't
compress as much, right? And then also all the
systematics are there, I did a feature importance.
In terms of prediction of the profiles,
time is the most important well, of course,
the liner aspect ratio matters a lot, because
that determines the acceleration. The next
thing that really matters is the size of
the perturbation. But more importantly,
the angle of it. Since its inverse cascading
to the M equal to it matters, what the phase
is because it locks on to that and makes it
grow. Okay. But the but you go and see that,
okay, Tina matters, but not a lot, because that
only matters, that stagnation, okay? matters how
stagnated it gets. But then, but, you know,
five, four, and three don't matter at all,
of course, not everything's going into there. So
you cascade out of it. So it doesn't really matter
how much five, three and five, four, but you
really see this thing is now inverse cascading,
right? But you can actually see that each one of
these modes, you know, what they are physically,
you can make physical interpretations, you
know, based on it, and really get insight to
the fact that we're getting inverse cascades
of self organization, right. And so if you
go back down to Sandy and now and say, Well,
how are you reaching compression ratios of 200
Are the one right? We're self organized, right?
You know, yeah, we get growth to the instability,
but we actually self organize into a dumbbell.
And so we don't care how much it grows because
of the self organization and right associated
with it. This is actually really controversial,
actually, with respect to the fact
that we were seeing Bruce cascades,
right. But I think if you really look
at these little tiny men, literally,
we go and compress from what they compress it
Sandia on the Z machine from about a centimeter,
and they end up getting to perfect helical
threads of 20 microns in diameter each. I mean,
it's incredible, you know, if you look at and,
you know, the images that they end up having.
And so let me just go and get to the conclusions
here. And I welcome there's a lot I didn't have a
chance to show you because you're such an engaged
audience early on associated with this. But what
we really have is a transmit transformational
method, right? That's finding disease, time
invariant coordinates your eye that are really the
solution to the Hamilton Jacoby equation, right,
okay. We go from Thiele coordinates to little
P Q's. But then when you go and solve for that,
you know, that H right and those trajectories, you
end up going and solving for what the the solution
of the Hamilton Jacobi equation, which will be
big peas, big Q's, and ERP, okay. And also, by
the way, the, what you actually are solving for,
and let me go and give you the punch line in the
answer to a couple of different questions here,
right? If I go and take a look at the approximate
Q function, right, okay, which is actually
normally you go and say that it's a function
of little q, little p, and theta, right? Okay.
That's actually going and if you looked at it,
it's actually going and it's actually theta of
Q and P. Okay, in terms of that, that's actually
equal to the Hamilton's characteristic function,
or the action, right? That's a function of q and
cap P. Okay. And cap P is actually, what's your
act is one of the approximation parameters that
you're dealing with, right? But this actually
is the action, right? Okay. In terms of the
solution of the Hamilton Jacobi equation, then
if you x what is the policy, which is little p,
right? Okay. That's equal to the partial of w with
respect to little q, right? Okay, which is now a
function of little q, and cap P, that's actually
equal to the approximate policy of q, and cap P,
where this actually normally is just called the
approximation parameter, right? And then if I go
and find out where the partial of the energy
with respect to cap P equals zero, or that's
actually the angular frequency associated with it,
that will actually give me p is equal to P stars,
right? That now I'll go and say that the optimum
policy is nothing more than Q of p star. And the
optimum value ends up being nothing more than W
of q, p star, right? And if you now go and take
a look at Deep reinforcement learning, right, I've
answered a lot of those questions I posed at the
beginning, but it's just simply in the context of
it, right. And also, you're probably aware of this
chasing your tail lack of independency, lack of
stationarity, right? And what was happening was
that as you go through the iterations and deep
Q learning, you're actually tracing things out
and you're converging down to p star. And
you're actually the fact that they're non
stationary is the fact that P is changing as
you're actually moving to p star. And all of
this replay shenanigans is so that you actually
are approximating W of q or p. And as you're
converging in you're actually tracking out what's
actually happening in those cases, stride so
that, you know, you go and find that this
is first of all the reverse the reduced
order model of artificial intelligence. I
think that it's what if you take a look,
I think it's what generative pre trained
transformers are transformations are learning,
they're learning this transformation just talked
a lot about, you know, what's happening in deep
reinforcement learning. And you know, in terms
of what it's doing here, and I have a lot more
detail in a paper, you find out what this
decoder encoder is finding it's a solution to
the Hamilton's Jacobi equation, all motion is now
geodesic motion, right on this little p q space.
And that this analytic Hamiltonian is just a
solution to Laplace equation. And then finally,
the topology of the low order dimensional manifold
is you're doing a topological discovery, right?
You saw how this has finished physical
meaning and interpretation. And I talked
about very early on the extrapolation and
the causal analysis associated with it.
Also, that for the
in terms of the Hamilton, you know, the
Heisenberg scattering transformation,
I've called it that because of its relationship,
the Heisenberg s matrix, by the way, right.
It's an excellent metric it did expose is
this fundamental underlying low dimensional
dynamical manifold. But also it goes and finding
the exposes the fundamental geometrical objects,
or these relaxed states, or the singularities
or beta stars, these are the ground states to
quantum field theory that attracted manifold a
nonlinear dynamics, the emergent behaviors and
self organizations of complex systems, Taylor
relaxed states and BGK modes of plasma physics,
the poles and branch cuts of control theory and
complex analysis. But really, fundamentally,
you're getting at the homology classes of the
topology, the real fundamental stuff of the
topology. And that's actually what's being
learned, right? Your brain at the very core,
just goes and finds out what beta stories
are. Right? And from that, it can inverse
reconstruct everything that's happening, it can
figure out how to go and control the system,
right? About these optimal points, you know, even
you can think about it in the start thinking and
psychological context, how do I control my
thoughts to stay in a good place, right?
You're actually controlling your your brain, that
complex system, your brain to stay around one of
those x points, right, that you'd like to go
and stay at, rather than going down to one
of those local minimums? Or that global minimum
of mental depression? or mental illness? Sir, I
actually mean this in a big way, not a small way.
Right. associated with it. I think that there are
really profound uses of this in terms of also even
the understanding of psychology, and I'm actually
working with some psychologists associated with
the use of this model. So, you know, they're huge
questions, you know, going on. But that's really
where I said that, you know, there are a lot of
different places where this actually comes in.
And in a way, it's a smash up of the learning
of this in terms of getting to it. Right. And let
me just go and I had one question in the beginning
to in terms of what is Q learning, right? What's
learning the action, right? But it's also going
and learning that analytic continuation, because
the imaginary part of the Hamiltonian is what I
would call cap Q in terms of the solution. That's
nothing more than the partial of the of the w with
respect to cap p, right? And that's the imaginary
part of the Hamiltonian. And so by finding w is
actually finding that complex continuation of the
Hamiltonian, which are the phase trajectories,
or the generator function of the canonical
transformation that generates the motion is
another way of looking at it. So thanks very
much. Thank you. Yes, thank you. Oh, speaker.
Audience home and abroad, you might say,
I have a question that I'm going to
hold myself back and see if people
in the chat or elsewhere I'm not sure how
we can see that here. Have any questions?
No, we don't have any questions. Okay. Looks
like a lot of people were on at different times.
Yeah, okay. So
they had a gun.
I'm sorry, good. They can unmute
and ask questions. Okay. So
all right, I'll start out with a question then.
So
involve everything. But one thing, you
know, again, from a big picture viewpoint,
is the efficiency and also the capturing of
kind of dicey topological singularities on this.
How much better is it than existing methods?
And what kind of problem? Let's say,
you're talking about pulse power, you know, what
kind of physics problem could you treat that you
couldn't do before? So you gave very impressive
numbers for your system, versus I guess, I guess,
a brute force calculation of an of an imploding
liner, it looks like you've got these sort of
semi really tailor things about right, and some
nice stuff in those pictures. But being a little
aggressive about this, is where could you go
with this that you could not do before? What
kind of problem in physics? Could you solve?
You know, that was impractical previously?
That mean, I think that
the I have
that the dough First of all, in terms of
performance as machine learning, right,
okay. That not having to go and train the
convolutional networks is absolutely right,
obviously, right? I mean, the
training becomes trivial, you know?
Right. And that, you know, 10s of millions of
dollars is taking up, it's really tough for
Deep Mind with alpha fold, etc. I mean, they
really burning large amounts of computer time
associated with that, right. Okay. Other things
in terms of causal analysis, right? It goes and
gives framework, right? Where you can actually
Well, first of all, it gives fast care high high
Fidelity's surrogates that go and conserve all the
proper quantity, so on when I say high fidelity,
that you can serve those quantities that actually
go to the right emergent behaviors, right,
okay. And don't have the issues of wandering so
far away from the physics or having, effectively
numerical dissipation in the light, eventually
eat your lunch, okay, long term, no matter
how high ordered the methods are, right. And
that's absolutely central to being told to have
any type of Bayesian analysis,
right, or post Bayesian analysis,
you need a very fast surrogate associated with
it, you need to attend to the second surrogate
to be able to go and do that type of analysis.
So it goes and we'll go and, and enable that,
right. But also, though, too, is that I mean, I
think it's, you have to go and say go supporting
causal analysis is huge. Because it can go and
start knowing when your data is whispering at
you that there's going to be trouble when you
scale up your experiments, right. And you have
ways of hypothesis testing. Of all we're getting
some new physics. And if we actually brought in
that new physics and actually ran it again,
with the new physics, you know, scaled up,
you'll start realizing that some physics we've
been neglecting is eating your lunch. Right. Okay.
So you can in I think it's an overall, I think,
challenge, I don't think that different methods
don't support the causal analysis, right? Because
you don't know what you're getting. You don't know
what these variables are in the right. And you
can't go and do those hypothesis testing of,
do I have all of the right directions and or
the those directions in the right direction,
right associated with it, right? And I wouldn't
be much more positive with respect to these
singularities. Right. I mean, that, you know,
they aren't like, you know, painful, you know.
They, they they aren't painful annoyances. They
are the answer. Right. Okay. So that, you know,
the, it's not that there's something
that allows you to get around. No,
it's something that you actually that
is the answer that you want to get to,
man. It's like Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy. Well, I can tell you the answer,
but you're gonna like it ride. This beta
star, right? Is what the answer is. So the
singularities are everything. And you
know, and don't and also in terms of
renormalization just itself, that, you know,
this is not you know, where you have to,
you know, have, you know, divine inspiration
of how to collect all the singularities. This
actually is a prescriptive way of you do it,
and it collects the singularities for you,
right. So I think in terms of even analytic
renormalization of field theories, that it will,
on the analytic side, give you a way to go
and get the solution to the renormalization
equation. And also, I think I like
the point is much more profound,
to be able to, I think it has real implications
about finally unifying gravity with the other,
you know, field theories that we have, right?
Because I mean, I think that Murray gell Mann,
you know, obviously, in his life's work, really
went in terms of the quantization of the particles
and fields of Su one, two, and three, really went
and had all those things, but it actually will go
and I, in the thinking that I've had, I think
this has a real ability to bring gravity into
the fold and put it on a common ground with the
quantization so that we actually have in terms
of Su one, two and three, right, which is the
e&m weaken strong forces, for instance, right.
You know, the electron posit,
you know, the electron positrons,
you know, nor normal barberry ons and the quarks.
Man, I have a question. Yeah, sure. Oh, hey, Mike,
this is Milan, can you hear me?
It's true. Milan, Milan. Hola.
So the question is,
it seems like we are trying to find a balance
between stability and accuracy. And so usually
the would work with entropy, it's like a
good measure. And so in your framework,
could you comment on the sense of entropy
when defining the topology of your manifold?
If it's if it's like meaningful, I can input like
a number, okay, this manifold is entropy. And
so do keep keep the singularities
but keep the dimension lower as well.
Um,
that I mean, the one thing to
go and note about this an item,
I'm going to take it on board in terms of
the exact mapping to the part of entropy,
but the the thing that you are looking at here as
it goes and interacts with the external systems,
those are the actual thermal forces that you
know, I was going and looking at, and that
there is a, and I'd have to go and and,
Megan, I really have to think about that. It's
a very good question. And let me really think I
can't say offhand, and I haven't really thought of
what Where is entropy and what I'm talking about?
Thanks. Oh, she's got an email. Okay.
That'd be really good. If you could,
yeah, send me an email, and I
will respond. Awesome. Thanks.
Well, I don't have a question,
but I have a comment.
In in the perspective of reduced order model,
a lot of people just apply the
PCA, so called a pod proposal. And
when you do that, it's you
don't get the rate compression,
that compressed social representation,
when you apply that to protection domain
problems or transport problems, but a lot of
the limiting factor dynamics
are driven by transport. So
you know, people recently they
started to add a neural network. The reason being
is there is a nonlinear activation functions,
you can actually map in nonlinear functions,
so that you don't have to rely on the linear
compression on me, but I see your work
of a PCA component. And also HST
fits in both with a global rating
transformations with a Hamiltonian and
then beta on layer MLP, which also has a
vector
by Liu,
the activation function, I can see that you,
you have all the components, you know, what
we do, usually, to perform a division. So,
but in addition to that training is a lot cheaper
than the usual neural network training, right?
Yeah, I totally agree that, you know, that's very
advantageous. I myself wanting to apply this to?
Yeah.
I mean, if you go and take a look at what is
here, and you can go and see how what's here is,
is reflected in WhatsApp know what you've ended
up? What works, right. Okay. And you can you can
see mappings of this and the structures and
the lie, and say, Yeah, this is, you know,
I see where this is happening. But it's like, but
there are no things to fit basically, right? Other
than the PCA, right associated with it, which is
a trivial operation right in the end, and that
you're right, that they realize it didn't work,
right. If you're working in the field domain,
you see the huge HST here, in order to be able to
get it into the domain where it is linear. Right.
Okay. And but then it's only linear, you're
confined to this hyperplane. Right. Okay. And
so it's linear with respect to the fact you're,
you're confined to a linear subspace, but it's
far from linear in that subspace, right. It has a
very, you know, rich topology, you know, in that,
that that subspace, but it is not so easy. But
but but in the end, though, it's not that rich,
right? I mean, there are only a few singularities
in that subspace, that determined the whole thing
around. Right. Okay. And so that, you know, the,
you know, in terms of where you normally go in
the convolutional network, so I are all trying to
get down to where this space where it is linear.
And that they actually will go and get into a
space where it's not linear, but it's curve drive,
okay. And then they'll use an MLP to actually
snap it to linear, right. Okay. And then,
you know, but by construction, they're kind of,
you know, they don't need to do the PCA anymore,
right? Because they have that nonlinear mapping,
right? So the convolutional parts of it are just
getting it. So it's there, but a bit curved. And
then they have to go and snap it. But if you've
done it correctly, it's already linear. So you can
just use a PCA without having to have an MLP at
the end of it. Right. Okay. But then once you're
in that space, and get the projection into that
reduced order model space, that there's another
thing of finding out what the Hamiltonian is,
right? Because you need to know what the
trajectories are. And then an MLP is great
for that. Because, you know, it's single value,
no need goes ways in single value. But it just
has a couple branch cuts and singularities
and you know, in MLP, eat set stuff up, right,
associated with it. So you're right, it has those
different the character of the stuff in there.
But you know, because I know it's a solution
to the Hamilton Jacoby equation, right. Okay.
And it has the form of that, and I didn't,
you know, have the time to show this right,
is that
I can actually structure a web of
MLPs with specific number of nodes,
where I know exactly what that note is going to
be. Right? If I looked at it, that is what what
those things are, right. One is the actual, you
know, the wq cap P. The other one is E sub p,
right? The other ones are the cap peas. Another
one are the big cubes. Right? Okay. And so that
you now have gone and further constrained the
network, right? To actually match the solution
for of the Hamilton Jacoby equation, right? But
there were cheap ways of doing this. Because that,
and that's what I did here, because if I know
this has 15 nodes, then I just have P Q. I have
some layers in between, right? And I just know I
need to have 15 things here. Right? Okay. So this
is kind of I don't know what's what they could
be admixtures of each other, right? But when
I look at this structure, there's no no doubt
about what things are and so you program this
back into TensorFlow or you know, or pie torch,
and you can actually play these notes out and
those are p, right. Okay. sociated with it right.
And so there's much more intelligent design into
to what this does Hamilton Jacobi equation
solver is really what this is, and you know,
trivially what the propagator is right in
it. Or you can also know what the force
is in this and then you transform back
out. And those were things I didn't show,
right. This is how you use this
in terms of surrogate right?
Oh shoot, this is the guy have to do stuff to
force it here is that you start with initial
conditions, you apply the HST PCA, and you
get the initial conditions in terms of this,
you have an MLP that actually goes and gives
you the P naught q knots, right, I now have a
Hamilton's a cobia solver, which gives me cap
peas q naught. So I, I now have a propagator,
which I know trivially Okay, and then I get
big key big queues, I go and have the inverse,
which gives me little PS, little Q's, I have an
MLP, that gives me the output function in p and q,
then I have the inverse transform that
actually gives me the output fields,
right, that I ended up having, right? And so that
you know, you now you have the Lego block ride,
okay, associated with it. And you have a very well
constrained Hamilton's Jacobi equation. And this
has absolutely nothing to learn, where normally
you're spending $100 million to train that thing,
right? is associated with it. So and
then, you know, if I have a controller,
I just go and have the ponder mode of force
here, then I just go and give this and I'll
tell you what the force I need to apply
the system in order to stabilize it. So
let me suggest this summit.
If there's any last minute questions, this
would be a good time to ask them. Otherwise,
we're going to migrate up to your home away from
home upstairs. And so that's to remind people if
they want to drop by, that's building for ad one
room 2117 Not the one of the earlier messages
because the door was locked. So but upstairs,
it should be good. And, you know, look forward
to it. You know, again, I mean, now I encourage
you to come by and talk to me right now and the
person with the entropy question. I think it'd
be great if you stopped by and we could actually
discuss it and maybe do some research real time
at the farm. So let's yeah, I've got a fortunately
Okay, I
want to make sure you get a
series. Okay. Thank you, everyone.
So I guess we logged out.
Good.
Thanks for
is very different, but you guys are so in good.
Transcribed by https://otter.ai